I'm interested in the twin prime
conjecture so this is asking about
consecutive prime numbers P 1 as the
first prime which would be equal to 2
and there'll be the second climb P 2
which would be equal to C and you can
look at the gaps between the times so
the gap between 3 & 2 is 1 this is the
only time you can possibly have two
prime numbers which differ by exactly 1
and so the next smallest possible gap
would be a gap of size 2 it's only not
the case that all gaps become size to
you but the question is how many of
these gaps of size 2 so for example 101
and 103 are two rather large prime
numbers which differ by exactly two and
then the twin prime conjecture so that
this having two points which differ by
exactly two happens instantly after if
the twin prime conjecture was false at
some point you go along the number line
and then all prime gaps would always be
bigger than 2 but we don't believe
that's the case we believe that it
should be the case the twin prime
conjecture is correct
so no matter how far you go along
there's always going to be some bigger
primes and in fact infants that differ
by just exactly two so you can test this
on a computer and we found pairs of
times that just by exactly 2 with over
300,000 decimal digits and in fact they
are surprisingly common that it's
certainly not all the time but if you
look at the first how far you have to go
after a million to find a pair of twin
primes it's not very far if you look
after a billion it's not very far if you
look after a thousand billion it's
actually not very far until you start
finding Twin Pines most pines aren't
going to have the one after it been just
two apart but we still believe that you
should be relatively plentiful and so
far if you check on a computer they seem
to speak to you but whether it's really
2 all the way as far as you go is
something that you can't check on the
computer and that's where you need to
try and prove the real mathematical
result so we don't actually know how old
the twin prime conjecture is that some
people have claimed that it should go
all the way back to Euclid and it's
certainly the kind of question that the
ancient Greeks could easily have thought
about the most recent time where we've
seen someone really write down the
conjecture
he was just over 100 years ago by
Deponia MEAC but he actually conducted a
rather stronger more general form of the
twin prime conjecture that's a bit more
complicated it's not just gaps of size 2
but also gaps of size 4 and gaps of so 6
and so there's a suspicion that the twin
prime conjecture itself is rather old er
than that but we know it's at least 100
years old possibly thousands of years
old if we're still finding these things
way way down the number line and we know
there an infinite number of primes this
is a known thing if they did stop what
would stop them occurring like what is
their somewhat beast out there could
stop twin primes occurring it doesn't
seem as any roadblock to them happening
forever this is one of the interesting
and frustrating things about prime
numbers that often it's clear what the
right answer should be if you give me a
simple problem like the twin prime
conjecture you can think about it
heuristic lis a bit you can check in on
computer and you can quite quickly
convince yourself that this should
clearly be the right answer and you can
do it in a fairly confident way so lots
of problems about prime numbers we
believe we know what the correct answer
should be it's just that we don't know
how to prove it and the game is always
trying to rule out there being some very
bizarre conspiracy amongst prime numbers
that would mean that they would behave
in a lot of a different way to how we
believe that they should behave so
you're completely right that if the twin
prime conjecture was false there'll be
some strange switch that happens at some
strange point far down the number line
there's an absolutely huge breakthrough
by utang jiang just relatively recently
in 2013 who showed that although he
couldn't prove the twin prime conjecture
that too is a gap in front he often and
he similarly conclude that for the
gapping from he often he showed that
either 2 or 4 or 6 or 8 or some number
less than 70 million has to be a gap in
for me often so the get wasn't 70
million it was just somewhere between 2
and 70 million but he didn't know what
it was but he couldn't say which one of
these came with a gap but he was able to
show that at least one of these occurs
as a gap infinitely after and 70 million
might sound like a huge number to most
people it's certainly a lot bigger than
two for example
but before that we had no idea of been
how we could possibly prove anything
like this that he showed that no matter
how far you go down the number line
there's always these Prime's that get
clumped bizarrely close together because
when you start looking at really really
really big climb numbers part numbers
become quite there so if you're looking
at numbers with billions and billions of
decimal digits for example then suddenly
the average gap will be well over a
billion and if you look at even big one
to get even bigger gaps so typically
prime numbers will have these very big
gaps and he showed that no matter how
far you get on the number line you will
get these pairs that come really close
together at least compared to how they
typically look I guess earlier on in
2005 there was this earlier work of gods
and pimps and you didn't he came up with
a new method for thinking about the
print line congestion problems totally
related to it people worked really hard
to try and push goals and printing your
dooms ideas a little bit further but
there seem to be this big obstacle that
we kept on not being able to make
progress on and it was this problem
which etang jiang managed to break
through came as a complete shock to
everyone I think precisely because
people had worked so hard on this
particular approach and all the experts
had been completely stumped on this so
70 million is a slightly our team our
number that just comes out of the method
and in fact his method really just
showed some number and he didn't try and
optimize the 70 million too much so if
you take exactly his antonyms but your
ever so slightly more careful the
numerical calculations you can bring 70
million down to 30 billion and then if
you tweak his arguments and we arrange
things ever so slightly it's still
fundamentally the same argument is what
he had but you can bring 30 million down
to 20 million and so as soon as you turn
Jencks result came out there was this
huge excitement at the result in time to
understand as oh but it also became a
small online competition amongst
mathematicians as to how low can you
make the gap that we knew 70 million was
an upper bound this is the first time we
had a finite bound but we also knew that
by tweaking the arguments you should be
able to bring 70 million down to some
smaller number
how low could you go just using what he
had put out there and and putting in the
extra work so there was a polymath
project which was a big online
collaborative project that set up
precisely to try and optimize the
arguments in Jiang's work now they came
up actually with quite a lot of neat
ideas to make Jiang's argument as
efficient as possible they were able to
bring Jiang's bound of 70 million down
to I think four thousand six hundred
eighty so I'd actually been thinking
about a completely separate approach to
this span of gaps problem before Jiang's
work came out so I was super excited the
chunks that came out is fascinating to
me because I was a fill a PhD student at
the timing side it'll disappoint it like
you feel about now I've been beaten or
were you really excited so I never had
any belief that my ideas would lead to
bandgap string times in any way so I was
just excited I think you're always super
excited when you suddenly one of these
big results comes out and you know that
collectively we understand something new
about prime numbers so I was just
desperate to get into the details of
Jiang's work there's always this intense
frustrating game that you play when you
do mathematics that you sort of feel
that you have an idea but you don't
quite know exactly how it fits in and it
takes a long time or fumbling around in
the darkness before you really get an
intuition for how what you think about
works it's a huge motivation to me that
this is part of the fun it's the chase
of the problem and trying to understand
what's going on so I was still
completely addicted to this thing that
I've been working on and I viewed it as
a side benefit it might actually be able
to help this big collaborative project
if I could sort my ideas out but then
the huge surprise to me was that
actually once I managed to grasp a hold
of this and look at things in from the
right perspective a variation on the
ideas that I was thinking about were
able to prove banner gaps in a
completely different way to Jiang's work
this gave a completely new way of
proving bana gaps between times so both
my work in Jiang's work is very much
based on the earlier work of ghosting
continue deer and golden continued doom
used an argument that's fundamentally
using a technique known as CID met
they prove the great result about primes
which come close together and they said
if we could prove this other technical
result that isn't to do with submitted
then we'd be able to get down a gaps
between primes and so what Jiang managed
to do is essentially prove something
like what they wanted to prove and
therefore use their argument to get
bandgap string x whereas my approach was
based on their original ideas rethinking
some of the way their original argument
worked which meant that you didn't need
such a strong technical input and so I
could use weaker results that be known
for the past 50 years or so instead on
the one hand I tend to sort of feel my
way to approve and know it's right
before I actually write down all the
details so I did have this feeling that
yes this has the feeling of being right
but at the same time I remember being
pretty scared when I first came up with
the ideas because you know I was going
to be very much putting myself out there
and it's very important for
mathematicians to really be strict with
themselves to check that they've got all
the details right but you often have
this internal feeling about these things
and it felt like to me I was really
surprised so yeah there was suddenly
lots and lots of interests I was a
postdoc at the time in module when this
came out and suddenly I was getting
invitations to fly all over to give
talks in different places in the u.s. so
it was really exciting for me being able
to meet all these famous mathematicians
give talks of my work suddenly everyone
was very excited I hadn't really
expected this at all I thought you know
as pleased that I'd proven a nice result
but I was more pleased because I'd
finally managed to get an understanding
of these things and I get I had the
satisfaction of the proof I hadn't
really expected there to be any media
interest or all these people asking me
to give talks and things so some people
have called it the main our towel method
so Terry towel was also thinking about
similar ideas he was very actively
involved in leading this polymath
project and so he came up with
essentially the same method at the same
time it's another bizarre coincidence
that there were does this one prove by
eating jank that came out and then both
Terry and I came up with this new
alternative method so some people been
calling it the Mae
our towel method so the current state of
e are trying to optimize all these
techniques including with these new
method and these new ideas is that
they're infinitely many pairs of primes
that differ by no more than 246 we
expect that every even number between 2
and 246 occurs is it different in
particular we expect to but we know
there's at least one between 2 and 246
can your method get us to 2
unfortunately there's a fundamental
barrier to our method get' my sequel to
to you so in some later work we said
that if you are really optimistic about
how you could maybe get all the
technical stages of the argument to fit
together and if you able to prove these
other very strong results that were sort
of strong versions or before you Tang
Jiang managed to prove then maybe you
can just about push our methods to get
gaps of size at most six infinitely
often but we also showed that there's
not going to be any small variation on
these sorts of ideas that can really get
down to two so you can get closer to but
not quite all the way there's a new idea
that's needed to get all the way to the
twin type of injection for sure the
reason for it is that we have these
mathematical devices that are trying to
detect time numbers but they don't work
perfectly there are only approximately
detected prime numbers so maybe they get
it like one in ten of the time or one in
six of the time or something like that
and if you're getting like one in ten at
the time then maybe if you're looking
for Prime's that come close together you
miss a whole load of being between
Prime's
but you still find two that are pretty
close together so you maybe missed out
10 of them but on the tenth one you find
one and there may be 10 times further
apart than you'd have hoped but they're
still pretty close to get there no
variation on these techniques even if
you're really optimistic
can ever improve your way of finding
Prime's
to 1 in 2 without using some extra
automatic information and really a big
new idea the fact that your proof has
this trait to it that it involves
approximation of things that aren't
always right doesn't sound like what I
mention a method
proof is I already sounds like it's a
bit hand wavy and wishy-washy I happen
to speak one of these classic rigorous
proofs if it's like sometimes a bit
wrong like so this is actually a common
feature of lots of modern mathematics
that you'll maybe take inspiration from
probability or engineering and you still
have to write down the rivers
mathematical proof but you maybe think
about the whole approach in a heuristic
way in a much less rigorous sense and so
you might think about lots of randomness
in your problem and you might be
deliberately trying to model prime
numbers as random objects and think
about them is not always being
definitive and things being a bit
approximate here and there and when you
write down your argument you have to
write it down in a very rigorous way but
all the intuitive ideas for why you come
up with that outline in the first place
often take an inspiration from rather
separate areas of mathematics and
science are you trying to find that
breakthrough that will take us to tell
you or do you feel like you've made your
contribution and this goodness um come
from another part of map or are you in
the hand still and I would certainly
still love to prove the twin prime
conjecture or something like that and I
do think about it on Friday afternoons
and things that somehow there's a big
new idea that's needed and at the moment
collectively I think we don't really
have a clue for how to go about that
someone needs to come up with an idea
and it's good to have these problems in
the back of your mind because sometimes
your subconscious just comes up with a
good idea out of nowhere so I like to
think about it on and off but I'm not
working full-time on the twin prime
conjecture now just because at the
moment I don't have a plausible approach
to how to get over their current bias I
still get my main motivation from the
problems themselves and I would
certainly claim I haven't I don't feel
terribly affected by the outside
interest the reason that I want to
understand things about prime numbers is
because I'm fascinated by prime numbers
and I really want to get into the grips
of the mathematical dirty details and do
this although I know that there's lots
of good reasons for being interested in
time
there's more generally for applications
in the world real world and there's
certainly interest that it can be picked
up on the popular press and things like
that
those aren't my personal motivation
somehow there's an inherent beauty about
prime numbers that's always what really
motivates me to try and understand the
mysteries of these seemingly very simple
but actually very complicated objects
but you don't get pressures it's not
like a boss will come up and say you
know change to be really good for us if
the number two came from here I
certainly not had any one car try and
get them forces to make me bring the gap
down so I've not felt any pressure
myself I can't speak for others
which one would you most like to see
solved which one would excite me the
most I think the Riemann hypothesis
would be the first choice for most
number theorists in terms of if you want
a problem on prime numbers the Riemann
hypothesis just automatically proves
about a million other theorem straight
away just off the bat that's all these
theorems that say if we're even
hypothesis 2 than this and so you
automatically prove a million other
theorems just with this and we have this
huge new understanding that even more
than the Riemann hypothesis as a result
the proof and the ideas and the proof
that prove the reading hypothesis
inherently must get such a good
understanding of prime numbers that we
will have this whole new way of looking
about prime numbers I would guess if
someone was able to prove the Riemann
hypothesis and this whole new technique
that would open up all kinds of new
possibilities so yeah if I had to choose
one it be the Riemann hypothesis does
the Riemann hypothesis ever get any of
your brain done I like to sometimes
think about some questions connected to
the Riemann hypothesis but the Riemann
hypothesis itself I feel I have no good
intuitive way of even starting to how to
attack that kind of problem but there's
lots of smaller problems connected to
the Riemann hypothesis that are very
important for par numbers and those are
things that I'm very interested in
certainly things about quite a lot yeah
likely to find your N you know your true
love because the prime numbers are so
far apart at that large ends of things
so it's a pretty loveless place you know
at that end of thing so you get a bigger
a bigger numbers you might think there's
just no way you're going to find your
true look